I understand you and your men have a job
to do hippo in the middle of a 10 year
olds birthday party I'm sorry but we
aren't coming in that's not a problem we
have nothing to hide from you my husband
is a good man don't mistake his honesty
for weakness he deserves respect this
was very disrespectful I run a fair and
clean business and I will fight till my
last breath to prove that these are
dangerous times we have to adapt it's
not like when we was driving there were
more murders and rapes in this city last
year than they have ever been so if you
come to tell me that we have an urgent
security issue here trust me I'm aware
this can't continue you're happy we're
here it's been two years and she started
investigating light industry do you have
any idea who's been doing this to us but
you may be doing something to bring this
on yourself no I have always taken the
path that its most right the result is
never in question for me
just what path do you take to get there
where did you get that who you
understand are found in the bushes
outside a front door it's not a brick
through a car window this is your kid
playing with a loaded gun Katie the DEA
is coming down with 14 count indictment
we've just pushed it a little too far
that's all can't have this situation
continuing if one of these guys shoot
someone it will be the end of everything
that we have worked for them you now
have serious legal cases against you
ranging from fraud to tax evasion it was
it your good luck helping you out all
these years it was
anything to do with this
when it feels scary to jump that is
exactly when you jump otherwise you end
up staying the same place your whole
life
and that I can do